So I can see that you have
some mechanism here and
in the specification file and
the generators for generating variance.
Can you give me an idea of kind of
variance that might apply in this
forecasting situation?
>> Sure.
So we already showed an example of the
most common case, which is what we call
a batch forecaster, one that generates
forecast for all the locations and
products that pertain
to a given retailer.
Some other variants on that are we might
want to generate forecasts not in batch,
right, not down in the database,
where they're materialized and kept.
We might want to
generate them on demand.
That is, we may just want to say,
all right,
well rather than having to wait for
the weekly or the nightly reforecast for
everything, I might want to
quickly regenerate a forecast for
some particular product, or
some particular set of products.
And I don't want to store
that result in the database,
I just want to get an answer.
We call that on demand forecasting.
>> Is this something that somebody,
at one of your clients
might formulate as a query?
>> Yes, yes.
In fact, in several of our clients
who use this service, they
have existing systems where they need to
be able to get an on-demand forecast.
Because they had traditionally
integrated with other systems that did
on-demand forecasting.
So we have to package up a service for
just that, and that service has to
involve all of the same algorithms that
we use to do a batch forecast, but
it's deployed slightly differently.
So that's an example,
batch versus on-demand.
Another example is, as I may have
alluded to previously, users,
forecasters, that is, the actual
employees at one of the retail clients
will often want to make adjustments or
do some what-if analysis by tweaking
the inputs to our forecasting algorithms
to try to see if they can get
forecasts that look more in line
with what they've seen historically.
That's not used a lot, but
it is something that is needed, so
the ability to do variance that
will allow for user adjustments and
for tweaking of inputs is
another common class of variant.
I think in this particular, I should
say, in the first application we built,
the first forecast manager application,
we built at least eight different
variants of the forecaster.
And I may be missing a few.
We may have made even some different
ones that we've used in order to test
that capability and
do the accuracy assessment.
So clearly you get a lot
of different variance.
I mean eight's a lot.
Right?
You wouldn't want to implement eight
of these from scratch.
You'd need to do something
to manage that variation.
>> And
can you show us an assembly spec for
one of these variance might look like?
So if you look at the slide that
is being depicted now, this is
the Hello World assembly spec that we
were looking at just a moment ago.
And this is a new one, a variant
that I'm calling Guten Tag Welt.
It's a variant of Hello World that
allows for forecast adjustment.
And if you look at this assembly spec,
you'll notice a couple of things.
So first, it's not exactly
the same as Hello World.
It's got some new components,
a new interface, and a new refinement.
In particular,
there's the mods component that
implements a new interface
called overrides that represent
some of the adjustment overrides that a
user of the system might want to make if
they're tweaking the inputs to the
forecast in order to see the effects.
There's also a new
refinement called dampener,
which allows multipliers to be
dampened by these overrides.
So typically in these applications, one
common adjustment scenario is to go in
and allow the users to change,
by some percentage,
the multipliers that our forecaster
calculated to compute uplift so
that they can see its impact
on the final forecasts.
And so what that dampener refinement
there is doing is it's applying
those overrides by virtue of
being parameterized by that
mods component to multipliers to
give us another implementation,
another component that implements
the multipliers interface.
And we can then use that in the same two
refinements that we saw previously in
Hello World increment forecast.
>> And the output of this
thing is the last line.
>> That's right.
>> You have a batch, but
it's an adjusted batch.
>> That's right.
>> Application that you built.
>> Exactly.
Exactly.
And it's a different component, so we
could actually put both of these in the,
install both of these in our database
if we wanted to, and then we would have
a batch forecaster and batch
adjusted forecaster if we so desire.